IN. OUR BEGINNING NOW.
EVERYBODY SET. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS WILL NOW
COME TO ORDER FOR EVERYONE CAN
TAKE THEIR SEATS. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY. AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS
AND SENATE STAFF- WILL- WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING AN ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENT TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WHILE CONDUCTING THE HEARINGIT
IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC
AND OUR EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL JUST IN
REQUIREMENTS- ALLOW. AND WILL
BE USING. A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE TO PLAY IT DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
HERE IN A MOMENT. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS NINE ZERO FOUR ZERO.
TWO SIX THREE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLICCOMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING AND HEARING. PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEDIAN SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS.
AND TO CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN
AND AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS CUSTOM MADE CUSTOMARY. THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WERE PARTICIPATING
TO USE OUR NEW ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
WE HAVE FIVE BILLS TO ON
TODAY'S AGENDA BEFORE WE HEAR
THE PRESENTATION ON THE BILL'S
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT'S THE. WHAT'S THE- YOUR
ODDS ARE. YEAH SO BY HERE HERE
HERE HERE OR HERE A WHITE WHY
CAN'T WE HEAR HER. OKAY HERE
MICROPHONE HERE THE MOST OF THE-
BUT AS WE ONCE AGAIN LET THE
DENNIS WITH A BRAND. WHEN I
JUST WANT TO CHECK FOR
MICROPHONE OKAY. HERE IT DOES.
THAT MIGHT WAS NOT ON. IF A
WALMART RIGHT. THAT'S RIGHT BOB
MAYBE IF YOU KEEP IT GOING
PLEASE KEEP CALLING THE ROLE
AND I BELIEVE. SHOULD THEY PUT
IT ON THE. OUR. I KNOW YOU.
HERE. WHAT'S SO HERE. THANKS A
LOT. PRESIDENT MORE LIKE
PRESENT. BRADFORD HERE BRADFORD
HERE. CHIANG YEAR CAN HEAR.
DOLLY DOLLY HERE. DODD THERE
DOT HERE. HERTZBERG AIR
HERTZBERG HERE. HELLO. HILL
HERE HILL HERE. MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
HERE. RUBIO PRESIDENT RUBIO
PRESENT STERN HERE STERN HERE.
WIENER HERE WE ARE HERE. THANK
YOU CHAIR WE HAE CORN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I WANT TO
REMIND ALL THE PARTICIPANTS
TODAY TO WAIT FOR THE
MICROPHONE TO BE ON BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING IN AND FOR MARK
MEMBERS ALWAYS TO SPEAK INTO
THE MICROPHONE AND IF ANYBODY.
WANTS TO SPEAK. TO RAISE THEIR
MARK MICROPHONE. NOW WE'LL HEAR
FROM THE FIRST AUTHOR. AND WE
HAVE SENATOR GLAZER HERE
PRESENT. A SENATOR GLAZERS FOR
PRESENTING THIS MORNING ON SB
EIGHT ZERO ONE PERTAINING TO
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS WELFARE
FIRE MITIGATION PLANS. THE
INTERCHANGES ATION AND PUBLIC
SAFETY PROTOCOLS CENTER GLAZER
WELCOME THANK YOU- THANK YOU
CHAIR HUESO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
OKAY NOT NOT YET. KLAY FOR THE
MIKE TO GO ON ALL RIGHT. SET
THE AIR THAT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S
WORKING NOW THANK YOU LET THANK
YOU SHARE WITH A AWAY SO THANK
YOU MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
UNDERSTAND MEETING UNDER
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES. MUCH
APPRECIATED THE SUBJECT MATTER
OF THE BILL TODAY IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT I HAVE WORKED ON
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME IN
FACT THE CAME AYE I'D ISSUE
MUCH MORE RECENTLY TO THE-
ACTIVITIES AND ACTIONS THAT
HAPPENED IN MY DISTRICT. BUT
THERE ARE MANY WHO HAD A LEAD
IN THIS AREA OF CARE FOR
MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMERS-
THAT NO ONE MORE THAN THE
CHAIR- WHO IS WORK ON THIS
ISSUE FOR MANY MANY YEARS HERE
HUESO YOU HAVE BEEN A LEADER IN
THE SPACE YOU HAVE WORK TO MAKE
SURE THAT MEDICALLY VULNERABLE-
CUSTOMERS ARE NOT DISCONNECTED
BECAUSE THE FAILURE TO PAY.
YEAH YOU HAVE WORKED- TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. HAS HAS A AT
REQUIRED THAT- THAT NEEDS SAID
TODAY THAT ARE WE ARE OF THOSE
IN THEIR CUSTOMER AREAS THAT
HAVE BEEN. YOUR MEDICAL. SO I
APPLAUD LEADERSHIP IN THIS BY
AND HAS BEEN FOR MANY. AND MORE
RECENT THIS PAST YEAR. I
SENATOR DODD HAS ALSO BEEN A
GREAT LEADER AND- WORK WITH
MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMERS IT
WAS HIS LEGISLATION LAST YEAR.
THAT REQUIRE THAT UTILITIES
CREATE A PROTOCOL. FOR HOW WE
DEAL WITH MEDICALLY. BASELINE
CUSTOMERS AND I APPLAUD SENATOR
DIED. AND HIS LEADERSHIP. LET
ME SAY AT THE ONSET. THE STAFF
OF YOUR COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
WONDERFUL TO WORK WITH THEY
WORK WITH ME AND MY STAFF. I IN
THE BILL THAT'S BEFORE YOU ANY
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
SUGGESTED WHICH I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT. TODAY BUT I WANT TO
APPLAUD AT THEIR THEIR HEALTH
AND OF THAT AND APPRECIATION
FOR. ALL THAT THEY HAVE DONE
AND OF COURSE IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR ME TO ACKNOWLEDGE MY JOB
AUTHOR ON THIS LEGISLATION. BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE WHO HAS WORKED
WITH ME ON THIS AND MANY OTHER
ISSUES IN THIS SPACE. SO I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR ANALYSIS
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR.
PROPOSING THAT THE AMENDMENTS
WHICH I ACCEPT. SB EIGHT OH ONE
WILL PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS. AS WE
ENTER THIS YEAR'S WILDFIRE
SEASON. AS AMENDED THIS BILL
WHY ARE UTILITIES PROVIDE
BACKUP POWER SOURCES OR
FINANCIAL SUPPORT. FOR THE
PURCHASE OF BACKUP POWER
SOURCES THE MEDICAL BASS LINE
CUSTOMERS RELYING ON LIFE
SUPPORTING MEDICAL EQUIPMENT.
IN HIGH FIRE ZONES AND- THERE
ARE MANY WHO DON'T UNDERSTAND A
SISTERLY WHAT IS A MEDICALLY
BUT AS A MEDICAL BASS LINE
CUSTOMER LET ME. PULL FROM THE
REGULATIONS AT LEAST AND GIVE
YOU SOME SENSE OF WHO ARE THESE
PEOPLE- THAT REQUIRE POWER THAT
REQUIRE THE SPECIAL
CONSIDERATIONS. THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT REQUIRE BREATHING
MACHINES DIALYSIS MACHINES.
IRON LUNGS OXYGEN GENERATORS
MOTORIZED WHEELCHAIRS. TOTAL
ARTIFICIAL HEART. WHO NEED
AIRWAY CLEARANCE SYSTEMS
QUADRIPLEGIC CONDITIONS. THESE
ARE PEOPLE WHO OF LIFE
THREATENING ILLNESSES OR
COMPROMISED IMMUNE SYSTEMS. AND
THEY REQUIRE SPECIAL HEATING OR
COOLING TO SUSTAIN LIFE AND
AVOIDED MEDICAL RATIONS. DURING
THE PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
OFF ADVANCED OF OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN OVER TWO
MILLION CALIFORNIANS DEALT WITH.
LOSING THEIR POWER IN FORTY
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THESE EVENTS WERE ESPECIALLY
THREATENING FOR A MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE CONSTITUENTS WHOSE
LIVES AS I DESCRIBED DEPEND ON
ELECTRICITY TO POWER THEIR
MEDICAL DEVICES. MORE THAN
THIRTY THOUSAND MEDICALLY
MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMERS WERE
AFFECTED BY THAT THESE PAST
POWER OUTAGES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR. AND AS
WILDFIRES AND PS PS EVENTS
INCREASE. MORE MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS WILL BE
AT RISK OF LOSING POWER TWO
DEVICES THAT THEY NEED TO
SURVIVE. SOME OF OUR UTILITIES
HAVE WORKED THROUGH NONPROFIT
OR OTHER AVENUES TO PROVIDE
SOME BACKUP POWER. TO A LIMITED
NUMBER OF CUSTOMERS. AND I
APPLAUD THEM FOR THAT. BUT
THERE VOLUNTARY MEASURES HAVE
NOT GONE FAR ENOUGH TO PROVIDE
PROTECTION FOR THOSE WHO NEED
IT THE MOST. AB SB EIGHT OH ONE
WILL MAKE SURE THAT MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CALIFORNIANS. ARE NOT
AT INCREASED RISK DURING PS PS
OFFENSE. BY REQUIRING THAT
PUBLIC UTILITIES PROVIDE THEM
WITH BACKUP POWER RESOURCES FOR
THEIR LIFE SUSTAINING
EQUIPMENT. THESE ARE A QUOTE
REQUIREMENTS WOULD ONLY APPLY
TO THOSE WITHIN HIGH FIRE ZONES
AND THOSE WHO ARE NOT
FINANCIALLY ABLE TO PROVIDE
THEIR OWN BACK UP POWER
EQUIPMENT. WE MUST NOT LEAVE
ARE VULNERABLE IN THE DARK IT'S
OUR DUTY TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE PROTECTED DURING THESE PS
PS EVENTS. WITH V. AS CURTIS
CHILD AND IT IS A DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE RIVAL.
THANK YOU AND IS- MISTER CHILD
ON THE PHONE. MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE- GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE'RE VERY
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
HAS- THE CLEANING IS CERTAINLY
HEARD- MANY TIMES AND THOSE
JUST ARE STRUGGLING SPIKE-
SENATOR GLAZER- THE IMPACTS OF
THE POWERSHOT ARMS LAST FALL
THAT WERE IMPLEMENTED BY. THREE
OF THE I. O. U.'S WORK
EXPERIENCING AN IMPACTED
LITERALLY MILLIONS OF CUSTOMERS
THROUGH THE STATE AND SOME OF
THE MOST THAT WERE IMPACTED
WEARING DETAILS- WITH
DISABILITIES- ELDERLY OTHERS
WITH ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL
NEEDS FOR THESE FOLKS.
ASSURANCE OF BACKUP POWER IS-
ESSENTIAL WE ARE RIGHT NOW ARE
WELL OVER THREE HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND MEDICAL BASELINE
CUSTOMERS IN THE STATE AND
THERE ARE REALLY ONLY A
PERCENTAGE OF THE ACCESSIBLE
PUNK. POPULATION IT IS A
RAPIDLY AND EASILY AT. STARTING
POINT AND THAT'S WHAT STILL
DOES. GLAZER RECOGNIZE STILL
AND STATED THAT THE LAW
PROGRAMS WHILE APPRECIATED TO
PROVIDE POWER SERVICE THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS RIGHT. NOW AND SO
LEAVING. THE CARD I THINK IT'S
YOUR KIDDING SEXUAL AND ALICE
NO THIS BILL WILL WILL YOU HAVE
BACK TO REACH BUT DO. REMAIN
FACT OPEN THE SPOT. TO THE-
POPULAR. OUR AND WE DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE FACT YOU IN THAT IN
WHAT THE PROTOCOL TO BE DOUBLY%
IN. WITH THIS BILL RIGHT ORGAN.
I JUST WANT TO ADD ONE OF POINT
THE CURRENT AND DAMAGE HAVING A
PRETTY HARD. IMPACT ON WITH
THIS AND THE L. AGE THEIR
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE LIFE REALLY
DEPENDS ON- SHELTERING IN PLACE
AND A POWER SHUT OFF- COULD
FORCE THEM INTO A DANGEROUS
ENVIRONMENT AND THAT MAKES IT
ALL THE MORE CRITICAL THAT
RADIATION BUT THEY HAVE BACK UP
WHICH- POWER RESOURCES TO KEEP
THEM IN THEIR. HOMES AND- I.
BUT THAT WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH THE WITNESSES HERE
IN THE GALLERY- MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE GALLERY
ANYBODY WISH TO COMMENT ON THIS
BILL EITHER IN SUPPORT. WE CAN
BEGIN WITH THE SUPPORT. IF NOT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. WE HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL'S
TWENTY FORTY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT AND SUPPORT. DO WE HAVE
ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY THAT
LIKES TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION.
ANYBODY TWENTY FORTY AND
OPPOSITION AND THEN THE PAIR
THAT THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
ROOM. OKAY THANK YOU. I WILL
MOVE ON TO. THAT WITNESSES
WAITING VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON
THIS BILL WORKABLE GONNA ASK
FOR EITHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IF THERE'S ANYBODY
ON THE LINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
HUESO AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS GIVING A PLUMBING AND
ON BEHALF OF PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY. WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AT THE
EIGHT OH ONE. ANY CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SET UP YOU'VE BEEN PRE
HARDSHIP FOR CAPITAL MURDER.
AND FOR CUSTOMERS WERE LIVING
CLOSE TO THE MARGIN IT CAN BE
EVEN MORE IMPACTFUL. HOWEVER WE
DO NOT BELIEVE SB EIGHT OH ONE
INCLUDING TO SUGGEST THE
COMEDIAN THEM AND PREVENT THE
BEST WAY TO HELP ON THE
POPULATION. WE BELIEVE SB ETAL
ONE WILL FORFEIT THE USE TENS
OF MILLIONS OF RIGHT HERE
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE BACKUP
GENERATION THE CUSTOMERS WHILE
IGNORING OTHER MITIGATION TOLD
THAT COULD BE UTILIZED TO
BENEFIT. THE BROADER CUSTOMER
BASE. IMPACTED BY PM YES. I
DEDICATE FINDING THE TYPICAL
MEDICAID TOTAL. IF THIS BILL P.
JEANNIE FOR FINDING OTHER COOL
THAT CAN. ADDRESS OUR DIVERSE
CUSTOMER NEED. PJ IS ALREADY
WORKING TO MAKE A READ THAT
THEY TO SUPPORT MEDICAL THE IT
AND OTHER CUSTOMERS BEFORE
DURING FUTURE. YES WE'VE BEEN.
PGA ANY WE'RE COLLABORATING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION
FOR IN LIVING CENTER. I MEAN
HOW THEY ARE ACTUALLY ACT FOR
FUNCTIONAL NEED COMMUNITY
BEFORE DURING AND AFTER A PS
YET THE BAND OR OTHER
EMERGENCIES. IF THEY HAVE A
AFFECT COMMUNITY INCLUDE PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES CUSTOMERS AND
ROLLED AND PGA ANY YOU NEED
MEDICAL BASELINE PROGRAM AND
THE AGING POPULATION. A
TESTAMENT TO THE COLLABORATION
BETWEEN PGA ANY AND THAT THE F.
I. ELT IS THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE DISABILITY DISASTER ACCESS
AND REPORT THIS PROGRAM. IT IS
ONE OF THE FIRST STATEWIDE
PROGRAMS THAT IT'S KIND AND HAS
A BUDGET OF FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. BY THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY. HIGHLY DIVIDE AND
BUDGET PROGRAM AND BUDGET WERE
DEVELOPED TO SUPPORT PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND OLDER
ADULTS AND PROVIDE FACTORED
GENERATION AS ONE SERVICE AMONG
MANY TO HELP CUSTOMERS COPE
WITH PS YET THE BAND OR OTHER
EMERGENCIES AND CLOTHING I'LL
SAY THAT YOU DO NEED BELIEVE SB
EIGHT OH ONE REQUIREMENT FOR
BACK AT GENERATION FOR ALL
MEDICAL BAY BY CUSTOMERS. IN
THE BANK THANK YOU OBLIGATION
ON THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
THAT DOES NOT NECESSARILY
ADDRESSED THE ONGOING EFFORTS
TO MITIGATE THE EFFECT OF
FUTURE PS YET THE BEEN PROPOSED
THAT I WATER MITIGATION PLAN
FOR THE ONGOING COLLABORATION
WITH ORGANIZATIONS THAT
SPECIALIZE IN ADDRESSING THE
VULNERABLE POPULATION. FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE HERE NO.
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR TO AYE AYE WANT TO
REMIND. THE COLORS THAT ARE
CALLING IN IF YOU COULD PLEASE.
AT THE OPENING OF YOUR
TESTIMONY AT GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND IF YOUR- TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF. OF ANY PARTICULAR
ORGANIZATION. AND ALSO TO STATE
AT THE OPENING OF YOUR COMMENTS
YOU YOUR POSITION. ON ON THE
BILL I DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER-
PEOPLE ON THE LINE THERE WILL
CHEN TO TESTIFY AT THIS TIME.
IN MORNING AND CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. NIGGLING AT ON IT WITH
ENDING A GAS AND ELECTRIC IN
OPPOSITION CAN YOU HEAR ME OK.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS MICHAEL
THE NET YEAH THIS CYNICAL
CATHOLIC CHECK PLEASE PROCEED
IN THE CALL IN. THANK YOU OF
pOF BALLING LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS AND WHAT YOU DID MADE
BY P. JEANNIE BUT I WANT TO
TOUCH ON THREE POINT- AND
BEFORE I JUMP INTO THAT THE
POINT. LIKE WHITE HAIR VERY
CURIOUS ABOUT- REDUCING THE
IMPACT IT. HAS ON VULNERABLE
CUSTOMERS- WE HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE MADE A SHOT
REQUIREMENTS- WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE COMMENTS ABOUT THE BELIEVE
RIGHT LANGUAGE IN THE BALLOT
WHILE GREAT. IMPACT I'M FOR. WE
DEAL- ALSO BELIEVE THAT IN
MANDATE THAT. A VERY. PRESIDENT
TO A VERY DYNAMIC ISSUE AS WITH
THE MENTIONED EARLIER AT THE
GOOD WORK THAT WE DID ON AT THE
ONE SIX SEVEN BY. SENATOR DODD
LAST YEAR EVERYONE IS FAMILIAR
WITH IN A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND AND I WE USE CAME
TOGETHER TO WORK ON. THAT ISSUE
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND WE
AGREED THAT MAIN LIKE THE
APPROPRIATE APPROACH BECAUSE-
EACH UTILITY. HAD THAT
DIFFERENT WAY OF BUILDING OUT A
PACKET GENERATION PROGRAM THAT
WE WERE ALL WORKING ON HOW
TOWARDS INVOLVED DIVERSE NEEDS
OF THE COMMUNITY- BUT AT THE
MENTION THAT ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH MAY NOT BE REASONABLE
IN EVERY CASE AND I WANTED TO
PROVIDE AN EXAMPLE AS WELL- LET
STATE CIRCUIT. ONE TWO THREE
FOUR EVERYTHING IS A HUNDRED
CUSTOMERS WHO WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
UNDER THIS BILL EVEN WITH THE
AMENDMENT UNDER THE BILL WOULD
BE. REQUIRED TO PROVIDE. A
BACKUP GENERATOR BUT LET ME
THAT IT WAS ON THE GROUND SO
WE'RE PROVIDING- BATTERY SEARCH
SO COOL MAY NEVER EXPERIENCE
DATE YET YEAH- SO THERE'S ALSO
THAT CONSIDERATION OUT OF-
PERHAPS. NEW TECHNOLOGY THE
TEACHER OTHER TECH THE
MITIGATION MATTER MEASURE THAT
THE BILL COULD POTENTIALLY
STRIKE SO AGAIN WE WANT TO
THANK. A BLANKET REQUIREMENT
WOULD TAKE AWAY OUR FLEXIBILITY
TO IMPROVE- WHAT WE SELL OUT
OUR CUSTOMER IN. PUBLIC FIFTY
PARTNERS NEED. AND WE DON'T
AGREE. WITH THE DEATH RIGHTS
GROUPS IN FACT WE ARE ALL
PARTNERING WITH GARY TRUST
NETWORK AND SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WERE PARTNERING WITH A CALLOW
YET A IF AND WORKING GROUP IS
WHAT THE PARTNER REALLY NETWORK
NETWORK. OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY ORGANIZATION. AIDS
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE DIRECT
ACCESS TO ACTUAL FUNCTIONAL
NEEDS INDIVIDUALS AND HAVE- AND
PROVIDE DIRECT EVERYTHING TO
THEM. THE MEETINGS ARE INTENDED
TO COME TOGETHER AND LISTEN TO
WHAT- HOW WE CAN BEST MEET
THEIR NEEDS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND THEY BRING THAT UP BECAUSE
I'M DISABLED CUSTOMERS ARE
INCLUDED IN THE DEFINITION F A
EVENT POPULATION AND GOVERNMENT
PROTECTION EIGHT FIVE NINE
THREE DOT THREE. AND ALSO WANT
TO MENTION THAT THE COMMITTEE'S
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS IN AT EIGHT
SIX TWO WHICH WILL BE HERE
LATER ON TODAY- ALSO ADD THAT
INTO THE LANGUAGE YOU WILL
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS THE BETTER
APPROACH- TO. THAT WOULD ALSO
GET OUT THE AUTHOR. BONTA THERE
ARE. CHANGE THERE WILL BE A
GREAT HERE AND HAVE. AS
MENTIONED ARE W. OR WHAT MAKING
PLAN WORK IN SHREDDING THIRTEEN
POINT TO MY DOLLARS TO TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWO OUR CURRENT CRAP.
OUR GOAL IS TO HELP WITH MANY
CUSTOMERS POSSIBLE IN THE
HIGHEST WITH. CONSIDERATION ALL
THE FIFTH HARDENING INVESTMENT
THAT WERE IN TO DO. TO MAINTAIN
BETTER REGULAR. THAT REPAIR
COSTS ME NOT HAVE THE INTENT
BENEFIT. IN CLOSING OR
PACKAGING IS COMMITTED TO
ENHANCING CUSTOMER AND
COMMUNITY RESILIENCY WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND THAT
HE MADE PROPOSED AMENDMENT- BUT
IN OUR IN OUR TEAM IS CURRENTLY
ANALYSING- THE POTENTIAL IMPACT
THE CREDIT FILE. HAVE TO
MAINTAIN THAT IT DOESN'T
ADDRESS THE BROADER CONCERN AND
TAKING AWAY OUR ABILITY TO BE
ADAPTABLE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR CUSTOMERS AND OUR CRITICS
OF THE TERRITORY AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I RESPECTFULLY ABOUT THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
IN ON THIS. I'D I'D LIKE TO ASK
SMARTER MODERATOR IF YOU CAN
PLEASE GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE. WAITING IN ADD TO
TESTIFY ON THE LINE DO WE HAVE
THAT NUMBER. ADAM THE- CARD-PEOPLE THAT WANT TO COMMENT THE
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO COMMENT ON
THE LINE. OKAY IF YOU WANT TO
MAKE A COMMENT YOU NEED A PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. RIGHT NOW
WE JUST HAVE A LINE THIRTY
SEVEN. GO AHEAD. WHAT BACKING
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN PORT. ANY OTHER
PEOPLE ON THE LINE. WISHING TO
TESTIFY. YEAH WE HAVE THREE
MORE ONE MOMENT AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE THEIR LINE NUMBERS.
I'M NECESSITY FOR. THIS. ONE
MOMENT WE HAVE TWO ONE. ALRIGHT
MY NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN MY NINETEEN.
PLEASE I NEED A FAIR MUTED. CAN
WE GO TO THE NEXT LINE. ONE
MOMENT. THAT'LL BE A LINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THIRTY
LARA DUTTA BLOOD AT THAT ON
BEHALF OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON WE CURRENTLY HAVE AN
OPPOSED POSITION ON THE BILL
AND WE ARE REVIEWING THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT THE
COMMITTEE AN HOUR. LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR TO
WRITE ARE CONCERNED THANK YOU.
THE CALL. THERE'S NO ONE OUT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME OKAY WE
DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER SPEAKERS
ON THE LINE WILL COME NOW TO
THE COMMITTEE ON THE BILL. YOUR
COMMENTS OF MEMBERS. ON THE
COMMITTEE OR QUESTIONS. MEMBERS
ANYONE. LIKE TO ENTERTAIN
ACTION. SENATOR HILL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'VE- A WILL MOVE
THE BILL AS AMENDED. HOW DID
YOU WANNA MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS SENATOR GLAZER THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN THAT I WANT
TO SAY TO MY FRIENDS THE DETAIL
OF THE STATE. I RECOGNIZE THAT
THE THESE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE NOT
NECESSARILY IF YOU'RE DOING IN
SOME CASES AND OTHERS THAT
THERE'S SOME ISSUES- OF
NEGLIGENCE BUT I KNOW FOR THE
MOST PART NONE OF US WANT TO
CREATE THIS CIRCUMSTANCE.
CALPERS OF IN THE- BASELINE
THAT CONDITIONS I WANT A AND
SUMMARY CLOSING NOW THAT- THE
NEW TECHNOLOGY IS AVAILABLE
UNDER THIS LEGISLATION TO TAKE
COVER THE RIVER THE
RESPONSIBILITY AND THE BILL
DOESN'T SAY YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
GENERATOR SO THERE ARE
FLEXIBILITY AND THERE IS
OPTIONS THERE. THE GOAL OF
COURSE OVERALL IS TO REDUCE THE
S. P. S. AS WE KNOW THE
UTILITIES ARE WORKING ON THAT
AND THAT COULD BE IN SHORT
ORDER THAT THIS REQUIREMENTS IN
THE BILL WON'T BE NECESSARY
BECAUSE THEY ALL OF HARD THIS
IS THE PROGRAM. FINALLY I THINK
THAT THERE'S A THE BILL
PARTISAN. THERE'S NIELSEN. OKAY
ALONG WITH BETTER TURN THEY'LL
DIE. AND OF COURSE JOINT
AUTHORED SENATOR MICHAEL.
FINALLY THERE A PHRASE GOES. IN
A LIGHT. POWERS LIGHT AND
THAT'S THE LIFE ON THE SEA. AND
THAT'S TRUE. BUT POWER IS MORE
THAN JUST KEEPING THE LIGHTS
ON. AND IT'S MORE THAN JUST
KEEPING STUFF IN YOUR
REFRIGERATOR AND FREEZER- FRESH
AND FULL OP PERSON HAVING ITS
FOR A WHICH IS. ANOTHER DAY
SIDE OF PSP. ACTIVITIES OUR IS
MORE THAN JUST A LIGHT AND MORE
THAN JUST KEEPING THE
REFRIGERATOR GOING POWER IS A
LIFE. LIGHT L. I. F. B. POWERS
LIFE. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
IS ABOUT IT'S TRYING TO HELP
PEOPLE WHO NEED POWER TO STAY
ALIVE IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL PART
OF WHAT WE DO IS
REPRESENTATIVES PROTECT OUR
CITIZENS THREE. THAT ARE THE
MOST VULNERABLE AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS LEGISLATION IN THE NARROW
SENSE ATTEMPTS TO DO AND WITH
THAT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOMENT TO APPROVE THE BILL WITH
WITH- THE SUGGESTED COMMITTEE.
AMENDMENTS CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SB EIGHT OH ONE
GLACIER TO PASS TO BE IN THE TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL BY WESSEL
I. MORE LOCK. INTO THE MY NOT
PLEASE IF FOR ONE COULD SPEAK
INTO THE MIKE STAND. THIS WEEK
MEMBERS PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONES BEFORE YOU VOTE.
BRADFORD. CHIANG HI CHEN AYE
DOLLY NO DAWALY NO DOT. I
THOUGHT I HERTZBERG. I
HERTZBERG GUY. HILL BY HILL AYE.
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE. RUBIO HI
RUBIO I'D- STERN HI STERN I
WIENER ALL RIGHT WIENER I. NINE
DAYS AND ONE NO. OKAY WE HAVE
THE BILL PASSES. OKAY THANK YOU
CENTER GLAZER. WILL MOVE ON TO
ITEM TWO S. B. EIGHT SIX TWO BY
SENATOR DODD. LATEST FOR CENTER
DOT TO TAKE THE PODIUM. WELL WE
DO THAT I WANNA AGAIN.
ANNOUNCED THAT DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS AND FOR-
REGARDING A TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS A NUCLEAR
PARTICLES CAMILLA COMMITTEES
WILL INSTITUTE TIME LIMIT ON
TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY EACH SIDE
WILL ONLY PER BE PERMITTED A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY
MUSLIMS THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME. AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURES SENATOR. PLEASE
WHEN YOU'RE READY MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS LET ME BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT
SUGGESTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. LAST YEAR I OFFERED
SB ONE SIX SEVEN WHICH REQUIRED
ELECTRICAL UTILITIES. TO SET
FORTH THE THEIR PROTOCOLS FOR
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF MEDICAL
BASED LIKE CUSTOMERS DURING A
DJ THE GENERAL. D. INTEGERS
ATION EVENTS. I'VE COME TO
LEARN IN ADDITION TO MEDICAL
BASS LIKE CUSTOMERS THERE ARE
ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS
CUSTOMERS A. F. IN REQUIRING
ATTENTION DURING A D. ENERGY
ASIAN AS WELL. AFN INDIVIDUALS
ARE THOSE HAVING DEVELOPMENTAL
OR INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES
PHYSICAL DISABILITIES CHRONIC
CONDITIONS INJURIES LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY OR WHO ARE
NON ENGLISH SPEAKING SENIORS
CHILDREN OR PEOPLE LIVING IN
INSTITUTIONALIZED SETTINGS. SB
EIGHT SIXTY TWO APART REQUIRES
THAT THE UTILITIES REQUIRED
THAT UTILITIES SET FORTH THEIR
DE ENERGY STATION PROTOCOLS FOR
THE AFM POPULATION IN ADDITION
TO THEIR MEDICAL BASELINE
PROTOCOLS. ADDITIONALLY EIGHT
SIX TO CLARIFY IS THAT A D.
ENERGY SAY SHOULD BE BAD COULD
BE COVERED UNDER THE PROVISIONS
OF THE STATE EMERGENCY SERVICES
ACT THAT'S THE UPDATE YEAH
THEREFORE CONSIDERED A DECLARED
EMERGENCY. COUNTIES MUST OPEN.
EMERGENCY OPERATION CENTERS IO
SEES WHEN NOTIFIED OF A
POSSIBLE DEALERS ASIAN. IF THE
ES IT COVERS THE LEGISLATION.
THE COST OF OPERATING A COUNTY
EOC CAN BE REIMBURSED WHEN THE
WHEN THE GOVERNOR DECLARES A
DEALER JUST SAY SHOULD BE
BETTER IN THE IN THE BED OF
ARMORED SEE LASSEN THAT'S EIGHT
C. TO REQUIRED TO DEAL
UTILITIES COORDINATE WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE SITE TO THE
RESOURCE CENTERS AND ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE OP. TWENTY HOURS
A DAY. DURATION DURING THE TWO
DURING THE DURATION OF THE T.
SAY SHOULD BE BACK. IT IS
IMPERATIVE WE HAVE SHE WERE IN
THE BILL DISPLAY STIRRED THESE
EVENTS COULD. OR TO WHERE THEY
CAN BE TO OR WHERE THEY HAVE AT
THE POWER ANOTHER SERVICES.
THIS AN OPERATION THESE CAN YOU
RESOURCE CENTERS MUST BE DONE
IN COORDINATION WITH LOCAL
OFFICIALS TO ENSURE THEY MEET
CRITICAL LOCAL NEEDS. I HAVE
COUNTY SUPERVISOR DIE IN JAIL
AND FROM NAPA COUNTY IT KERR
CHILD- FOR THE DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA ON THE PHONE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
VERY WELL DO WE HAVE THE
SPEAKER ON PHONE. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I AM DIANNE BILL
CHAIRMAN COUNTY OF SUPERVISORS
THANK FOR YOUR TO TESTIFY BURKE
FOR TODAY. THE HALF OF THE NAPA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AT
COAST. SENATE EIGHT TWO WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORT OF BILL THE CAN
THE MAN. EIGHT SIX TWO AND
PROPOSED AMENDED WILL CLEAR.
THAT PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHADOW.
YES THE BAN ARE INCLUDED THE
MERGE SERVICES BACK YEAH.
REQUIRES YOU. COME TO A ISSUES
THREE TO AND- WITH ACCESS AND
FUND NEED. IN A UTILITY
WILDFIRE. PLAN. OCTOBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NOT COUNTY HAVE
EXPERIENCE EIGHT. YES MA'AM
INITIATED BY KEY ANY SECOND
HIGH NUMBER ANY IN THE STATE.
DURING THE ARE TWENTY NINTH PM
PST MATHIS SEVEN MONTHS AGO.
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND MEETING ANY
MEAT. REPRESENTING A ONE THAT
RATHER WERE AND COUNTY WE
ESTIMATE THAT HE AND. OFTEN
AFRICA ASSOCIATE WITH THE TWO
NINTH IN A LOT. WITH ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND. I FOR FROM RAY COUNT
SERVICES BEING TO SO EMPLOYEES
COULD EMERGENCY I. CENTER EOC
AND ALMOST FORTY THOUSAND WITH.
DESPERATELY TO EACH THE
PREPARATION. HERE YEAH. NOT
RIGHT AFTER I ATE AND USED TO
SEE THE- ISSUE AFFECTED FPS ON
MERRILY THE NOTRE OF ONE EIGHT
EACH TIME. INCLUDING A FIFTEEN
THOSE WITH ACCESS AND
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS EVEN IF THE
ACTUAL P. FPS. DOES NOT. THESE
ACTIVITIES ARE COORDINATED
THROUGH AND BY A LOCAL AGENCY
WHICH ARE NOT INEXPENSIVE TO
OPERATE AS I PREVIOUSLY
DESCRIBED. CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
LOCAL AGENCY TO RECOVER SOME OF
THESE COSTS IF THE EMERGENCY
IT'S COVERED UNDER THE ESSAY.
HOWEVER IT'S CURRENTLY UNCLEAR
WHETHER IN EOC ACTIVATION COSTS
BY A P. PS AND NOW. COVERED BY
THE END DATE BACK WHAT SB EIGHT
SIXTY ONE MAKE CLEAR. WE
BELIEVE THAT WHILE THE CPC MAY
TAKE ACTION ON REQUIRING SOME
OF THE PROVISIONS IN SB EIGHT
SIX TWO. STILL NEED TO BE
CODIFIED NAPA COUNTY VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENT TO REQUIRE COMMUNITY
RESOURCE CENTERS TO BE
COORDINATED THROUGH LOCAL
AGENCIES INCLUDING WITH REGARD
TO BE OURS THE CENTER SHOULD
REMAIN OPEN LOCAL EITHER PLEASE
UNDERSTAND FIRST HAND WHAT
HAPPENS HAPPENING AT THE GROUND
LEVEL. HE CAN'T DO IT ONE FIVE
THE TALL MAN. NAPA COUNTY PROUD
BECAUSE AND EIGHT YOU AND WE
SINCERELY SENATOR DR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU. SENATOR YOU SAID YOU HAD A
SECOND PERSON IS A MISS CHILD
SO SHE ON THE LINE. YES I AM.
WELL MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE MANY THEIR- CHILD'S.
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND WE TOO ARE. THE CO SPONSOR-
THIS BILL JUST WANNA SAY WE
SHARE IN THE COMMENTS FOR
SUPERVISOR KILL AND- ON THE
CRITICALITY. OF CALL FIRING
THEIR POWER. WITHIN CITY SERVE
ARE. AND THE CRITICALLY WE
THANK YOU IMPORTANT BE A CLEAR
THAT THE NOTICE OF A POWER SHUT
OFF. THE ACTUAL NOTICE JUST
STANDING ALONE OF A POWER SHOT
OUT BUSINESS OWNERS. ARE PART
OF A DISASTER AS SOON AS THE
ACTUAL. SO WE THINK THATWILL
SERVE HELP INSURE THAT COUNTY
SAN THE RESOURCE. AND THE
ABILITY TO ACT PROMPTLY IN THE
OF THE HANDS OF THE POWERSHOT
US I JUST WANT TO. INSURE THAT
WERE- RECOGNIZING THE WORK BUT
SENATOR DODD DEBUT PARTICULARLY
WHEN HE STARTED ONE SIXTY SEVEN
SB ONE SEARCHING SO. WHERE THE
IMPORTANT STEP WAS EIGHTY TWO-
WE CHOIR THE UTILITIES TO HAVE
PROTOCOLS IN PLACE TO MANAGE
THE PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
OFF- AND- THIS. IS CRITICAL.
ARGUE SEE- THAT BEING
EXPERIENCE NOW- TO ALL. THE
CHANNEL LEADS WHICH YOU YOU'RE
CERTAINLY HEARD FROM. OF THAT A
THE AND SO MORE BROADLY INTO
THE POP. AND PARTICULARLY THE
WITH. LONG ABILITY AND WEBER.
IS CLINICAL DOOR THESE SHOT
OFFICE. AND FINALLY WE
CERTAINLY LEARNED HOW
INADEQUATE THE COMMUNITY
RESOURCE CENTERS- WERE LAST
YEAR THE HOURS WERE LIMITED.
ACCESSIBLE WHEN THEY ARE. A
POWER SO THERE'S STILL NOW
REQUIRE A- THAT THE RESOURCE
CENTER SO HAVE MORE BACK UP JIM.
THE LOCATED TO THE COMMUNITIES
THERE IN TERMS TO SERVE BE
OPEN- FOR TWENTY FOUR HOURS IF.
THE COUNTY. GERMANS IT'S NURSES
DURING THAT IS THE COUNTY
MAKING THE CALL AND THEN YOU
CHRISTIAN ACADEMY AND LET- YES
WILL CERTAINLY INCLUDES THE
OPERATIONS OF THAT YEAR SEASON
PROVIDE PROTECTION. AND
RESOURCES FOR WHO USE THEM SO
AGAIN WE APPRECIATE SENATOR DR
BRINGING THIS BILL AND
CONTINUING TO WORK OUT-
PROTECTING BALL NOBLE
CALIFORNIANS DURING THE SHOT
OFF STREET WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY WE'RE
GONNA GO TO PUBLIC NOW FOR-
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. OF THIS
MEASURE BEGINNING WITH ANYONE
HERE IN THE SENATE GALLERY. I
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. IF NO ONE
IS HE OF BUT WOULD LIKE TO TEST
FUNDS BILL WILL MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. ANYONE IS TWENTY
FORTY AND IF THE PEERS THERE
AREN'T ANY AND- TWENTY FORTY
WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. ANYONE IN
SUPPORT DO WE HOW MANY PEOPLE
DO WE HAVE ON THE LINE. I WE'VE
GOT FOR RIGHT NOW. FOR SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT I WANNA REMIND THE
SPEAKERS TO PLEASE TAKE YOUR
NAME. ANY ORGANIZATION THAT YOU
MAY BE AFFILIATED WITH AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. BUT A
LINE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD MORNING JIM BY
YOUR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIANS NEW NEW TWENTY SO
SHE CAN AS WELL AS MARIN CLEAN
ENERGY IT'S IMPORTANT THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS UP FOR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I LOOK AT
ONLINE FORTY NINE. DANIEL
SHOULD BE NO SENSATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES ALSO
IN SUPPORT. THE NEXT LINE THAT
LITTLE TOTALING THIRTY SEVEN.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
OKAY WILL GO TO THE NEXT LINE
PLEASE. NOT BE ONLINE FORTY
THREE. HELLO CATHERINE FRIEDMAN
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY INTO COURT ABOUT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
OTHERS ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE. I YES IT'S GOT
A FEW MORE NOW LINE THIRTY TWO.
CAN YOU PLEASE TELL ME AFTER
THE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK IN
SUPPORT. NINE THIRTY NINE NEXT%
LINE PLEASE HI JOHN KENNEDY WAS.
JOHN KENNEDY WAS THE WORLD
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANKS TO THE COMMITTEE IN THE
AUTHOR FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD
WORK ON THIS. AND MY THANK.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN WAY
TELLING COMMITTEE MEMBER GIVING
A PLUMBING FOR CONTENT IT
REPRESENTING PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY- WELL WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN THE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON A MANY
THE BILL PROVIDE GREATER
FLEXIBILITY WITH KNOWLEDGE IN
THAT COUNTY MIGHT HAVE
DIFFERENT NEEDS OUR COMMUNITY
CENTERS IN THE IN. EVERY
CHARACTER. DEREK ABOUT THE
STATE OF WORKERS IN THE CHEN
PUBLIC BY OPERATING TWENTY FOUR
HOURS YOUR NEEDS AND HELP TO
WORK THROUGH THOSE ISSUES AS
THE BILL MOVED FOR IT THANKS
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU MISS LIMóN ANYONE
ELSE ON THE LINE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE. NO ONE
OUT THERE THANK YOU AT THAT
TIME THE THERE ARE NO OTHER
SPEAKERS AT THIS TIME WE WILL
MOVE TO SPEAKERS IN. THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
OF THE MEASURE BEGINNING WITH
ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY. ARE
THERE ANY SPEAKERS HERE IN THE
GALLERY. IT APPEARS THAT THERE
ARE WILL MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IF THERE ARE ANY SPEAKERS
AT TWENTY FORTY. I WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. DOESN'T
APPEAR THAT THERE ARE WILL GO
TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE. ARE
THERE ANY SPEAKERS ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ON THAT WILL LET
ME ASK YOU CAN OPPOSITION HOW
MANY DO WE HAVE. AB A DIFFICULT
IN AGAIN WITHIN YOUR GAS AND
ELECTRIC IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
BEFORE. GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE AGAIN. WE WANT
TO SAY ON THAT PROPOSED
AMENDMENT WE APPRECIATE THE
PERSON INTEGRATING THE ACCENT
FUNCTIONALLY POPULATION AND
THINGS THAT- GOING IN A GOOD
DIRECTION BUT REMAIN CONCERNED
WITH THE LANGUAGE REGARDING THE
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTER IS A
PARTICULAR WITH IMPLEMENTATION
NINETY FIVE TOUCH ON THREE
POINT. REGARDING OUR CONCERN.
BUT FOUR HOUR OPERATE IT.
BECAUSE EIGHT WHERE ARE. EITHER
LOCATED IF THEY WERE TO BE OPEN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY DURING
YES IT WOULD ACTUALLY INCREASE.
THANK YOU TO OUR- ALL THE BOND
TO STOP DOWN THE QUALITY HOW.
WE STRONG MAIN. THAT IT OUR UP
WINDOW WITH MOST REASONABLE
BECAUSE I NUMBER ONE IT KEEPS
OUR WORK FORCE WELL INSURED
THANK YOU FOR AND NUMBER TWO IT
IS. IT ALIGNS WITH- ESTABLISHED
SITTING AND STRUCTURES THE ONE
MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS THE LINE.
OUR ABOUT SHOULD BE LIKE THAT
THANK CAN MEET THE NEEDS. AND
THE WHICH THE LIMITATIONS THE
NEXT ABILITY EXCHANGING THE
BOOK. FOR EACH PARTICULAR CAN'T
CAN'T PREVENT THE ALL TO BE A
BIT DE I DO WANT TO RAISE THAT
SOME OF THAT THAT WERE MADE
EARLIER ABOUT SHELTER DISAPPEAR.
PROPOSE NOTHING ON THE FACE TO
THE ENERGY THE GUIDELINES THAT
WOULD BE. ROLL I'M MENTION THAT.
EIGHT FAR OPERATE HERE HOPE NOT
PRUDENT AND- IT IS NOT THE
INTENT OF THIS YEAR THE
FUNCTION OF THE SHOP AND COOK
AND WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COULD THAT AS WELL THEY'RE INTO
DISTINCTION BETWEEN. GOVERNMENT
AGENCY AND NOT. EMERGENCY SHALL
THAT DURING TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY YOU PLEASE ENTER MY
CHECKING DOWN AND DIRTY THE
BRIEF THEY RELATE TO THE SITE
OF THE FEAR WELL TO KIND. FIRST
BITING HER AT LOOK AFTER
ELECTRIC GET INPUT FROM. A
LOCAL GUY ACT FOR WHICH IS WHAT
THE DAHLE THAT THAT WE ALSO GET
IN FROM WHILE FIRE BRIAN. AND
ACT IN YOU BRING IN THE
COMMUNITY DIFFERENT NONPROFIT
IN. AND AT THE VERY. DEAL GAP
LOGIC MAINTAIN THAT THIS.
SHOULD MORE. CAN INCLUDE THE
DIFF STAKE WATER OF THE MOMENT
TO HAVE LANGUAGE TO ALIGN WITH
THE PROPOSED DECISION A THE
WHEN AT THE DOCK. WE STILL HAVE
THAT CAN. ON HOW TO ALIGN BATCH
BUT OUR GOAL BEING COULD THEN
COME WHAT ALLSTATE AND- THE.
DURATION ON TIMING THE BILL
THAT YOU PROVIDE A MOBILE. AND
AT BEGINNING OF INDIAN. EVENT
IF THERE. ARE MET BUT I THE OF
THE CANDIDATES ABOUT MY BE TO
LATE IF WE ARE. PRO ACTIVELY
SITTING ON POWER PUBLIC SAFETY
IT'S SIMPLY NOT LET. CRACKED OR
STATE IS YOU START PULLING THAT
BACK IN JANUARY IF THERE NEEDED
TO OUR ANY CONCERN IT'S REALLY
BEING MORE. AND STRUGGLING IN
THAT. CREDIT TO MAKING SPECTER
OF REAL TIME DECISION BASED ON
THE AND FITCH AWARENESS ON CALL
EXCEEDINGLY AGAIN IT TO ENHANCE
BECAUSE AND WITH FEEDBACK HE
TOOK A BEST TIME COME SAFETY
THAT WE MAKE WE WERE THE ON AND
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU DOING. ALSO THE WELL THERE
ARE AND IT TAKES THE NEED TO
KEEP THAT THE IMAGINED HAVE WE
ARE AT THE END PATIENT NUMBER.
AND RIGHT DIRECTION THAT.
BETTER ACTS PUNCTUAL NEED THAT
I CAN WE HAVE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MISTER NON
THIS PROVE TO SPEAKER ON THE
LINE AN OFFICER. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER SPEAKERS. YES GOOD
MORNING SHARING MEMBER ALLOWED
OUT BY ON BEHALF OF SOUTHERN
CAL EDISON HERE WITHIN A HOLD
ON THE MENU ADDITION PRESS
EIGHT TWO SB SIX TO STRICKEN
THE CAR IN THE HARD MEDICAID
PLANNED PUBLIC PROCESS. THIS IS
A PUBLIC THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS BEEN THROUGH AND I KNOW ON
ME TEN FIFTY FOUR ANOTHER
RETAILER TO PLACE AN AD MOST
RECENTLY THE- BLOCK FIRED
EIGHTY DIFFERENT. ISSUE TRAFFIC
WILL BE AND WHAT MEDICATION AND
WITH THE DISH REQUIREMENT A
UTILITY EMPLOYMENT THREE EIGHTY
NINETY THE LIKELIHOOD CATCH
TRAFFIC CLOUT IN. TWENTY TWO.
THE REASON YOU DO YOU THINK I
DON'T THINK. FEEDBACK FOR TODAY
ANY MAKE TRACK OF. FOR CAN BE
RE CENTER. AND THE LIKE YOU
EIGHT SIX SECOND THE RY OF
REGULATORY. ENDING THAT
GUIDANCE FOR CAMINO RESOURCE
CENTER WE LOOK FORWARD TO A
WITH THE THEIR CREDIT THE SMALL
WE MUST RESPECT A PUBLIC ON
MONDAY AT. EIGHTY SIX TWO.
THANK YOU AND THIS IS A TIME A
FORUM IN OPPOSITION SO FAR
MODERATE CAN. ORGANIZE THE
OPPOSITION CALLERS PLEASE AND
IF WE CAN YOU MAY PRESS. ONE I
LOOK LITTLE LINE FORTY FOUR.
GOOD MORNING MR KAREN MEMBERS
DISTILLING HUNTER ON BEHALF OF
THE COURT WELL WE DO NOT HAVE A
FORMAL OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
DO YOU SHARE THE CONCERNS
ECHOED BY OUR SISTER UTILITIES-
SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
CENTER DOT AND A CHAIR- TO
CONTINUE THE- PROCESS. THANK
YOU FOR TAKE THE NEXT PLEASE.
WE HAVE ONE MORE ON NOW FOR
THEM IN JUST A MOMENT. NOW ALL
THE LINE FIFTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING HMM BIRDS MY APOLOGIES
I WAS NOT ABLE TO PETRIFIED
WHEN SUPPORT- WHAT ON THE SHOW
MUCH FOR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION- WE DO SUPPORT IT
THE EIGHT SIXTY TWO AND I
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE NEXT
SPEAKER PLEASE. THERE'S NO ONE
OUT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
CONCLUDES OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
ON THIS MATTER- DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. CENTER MORE
LOCK. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANT TO KNOW. AND FOR YOUR
MIKE TO BE ON PLEASE. SORRY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST
WANTED TO ASK THE AUTHOR- HOW
THIS BILL INTEGRATES WITH THE
CPU SEES EFFORTS RIGHT NOW
THERE IS ALREADY BEEN MENTIONED
BY THE TEST TESTIMONY BUT-
THEY'RE THEY'RE VERY ISSUED A
PROPOSED DECISION IN APRIL AND-
THEY'RE EXPECTING TO VOTE LATE
MAY SO I'M JUST KIND OF CURIOUS
HOW THIS INTEGRATES WITH. WHAT
THE CPUC IS DOING ON THIS ISSUE.
SENATOR THANK YOU I THINK
THAT'S A REASONABLE QUESTION-
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WHAT. WE HAVE
BEEN AWARE OF THAT OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE I THINK THAT WAS PART
OF- SP ONE SIXTY SEVEN BUT I
THINK THAT THESE NEW. THESE
THESE NEW REGULATIONS NEED TO
BE CODIFIED AT STATE LAW- AS
TIME GOES ON THERE YOU GO
MEMBERS OF THE- PCP YOU SEE MAY
MOVE ON. THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
EAST YEAH THESE DIFFERENT
BECAUSE THE TEROR
DISADVANTAGED AND WE THINK THEY
OUGHT TO BE CODIFIED LAW THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. ANYONE ELSE
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. WHAT IN A MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL OPPOSE ANY ACTION ON THE
BILL CENTER STERN ROOM. MOTION
FOR SENATORS. VERY WELL-
CENTERED ON WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MICHAEL CLOSING COMMENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND JUST
TO- CLARIFY THE BILL IS BEING-
MOVED WITH AMENDMENTS PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS- CLICK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SB EIGHT SIXTY TWO
DODD TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WESSEL BY
WESSEL I MARLA BY MORE NOT I.
BRADFORD ALL RIGHT EFFORT I.
CHIANG BY CHANCE I. DODD I
THOUGHT I. HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT.
HERTZBERG AYE. SORRY DOLLY HI
DOLLY I. HILL BY HILL I.
MCGUIRE HI REQUIRE I. RUBIO BY
RUBIO I. STERN HI STERN I.
WIENER HI WIENER I. AND I WOULD
LIKE TO REMIND THE MEMBERS TO
PLEASE SPEAK INTO THE MIKE
WHENEVER YOU'RE VOTE WHENEVER
YOU SPEAK SO THAT YOUR VOTE CAN
BE HEARD ON THE TRANSMISSION.
BUT MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT THE
BILL S. P. EIGHT NINETY FIVE I
SEE SENATOR ARCH LET IN THE
QUEUE. THIS IS A BILL
CONCERNING AN ENERGY IT WAS
ZERO EMISSION FACT
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGIES A
IF YOU LOOK FEEL- SORRY SIR
MISSION FUEL BEFORE- THE YOU
BEGIN CENTER JUST ONE OUNCE
THAT DO. OUT OF CONSIDERATION
FOR ALL THOSE PARTICIPATING IN
THIS PROCESS. WE ARE TRYING TO
LIMIT THE TIME OF TESTIMONY. IN
ORDER TO ACCOUNT FOR PEOPLE'S
HEALTH. AND TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AS WELL.
ACCORDINGLY EACH SIDE WILL ONLY
BE PERMITTED A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY. MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON THE
MEASURES OF COURSE- THE LEADING
TESTIMONY ON EITHER FOR OR IN
OPPOSITION WILL BE GIVEN A DISH
OF SOME ADDITIONAL TIME JUST
TO- EXPLAIN. OF MORE A MORE IN
DETAIL THEIR POSITION ON BILL.
BY SENATOR WELCOME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU A
JOURNALIST SO AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TODAY I AM PRESENTED
SENATE BILL EIGHT NINETY FIVE
THE BILL THAT WOULD AMEND AN
UPDATEAND INNOVATIVE NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE ASSEMBLY BILL THAT
ALLOCATED FUNDS FROM HEAVY.
DIESEL TECHNOLOGIES. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE THE NEWER
CLEANER TECHNOLOGY WAS CLEAN
DIESEL. AND WHEN ORIGINAL BILL
AND THAT ORIGINAL BILL WAS
DRAFTED IT DID NOT ALLOW FOR
THE UNEXPECTED ADVANCES AND
CLEANED TRANSPORTATION
TECHNOLOGY OF TODAY. NEVER THE
LESS THOSE ADVANCES HAVE
OCCURRED. AND THE INTERFERENCE
AND MORE IS TO COME. AT THIS
TIME TWENTY SOLD AT THAT TIME
CLEAN DIESEL WOULD DO IT WAS A
NEW FRONT CHEER LOWER INTEREST
CATION SHINS. AND SO EMISSION
REDUCTION FUND WAS ESTABLISHED
TO ENCOURAGE INVESTMENT IN THAT
TECHNOLOGY. HOWEVER NOW WE HAVE
A MULTITUDE OF ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES INCLUDING PLUGIN
BATTERIES AND FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLES THAT NEED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. MOREOVER
CLEAN DIESEL PROJECTS ARE NO
LONGER FUNDED AT THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION. THIS WOMAN A
GIVEN MORE PASSED THE
AUTHORIZING LEGISLATION IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE IN ORDER
TO INVEST IN THE NEW AS CLEAN
AS TRANSPORTATION FUELS. EIGHT
NINETY FIVE WE'LL SIMPLY UPDATE
THE INTENT THE INTENT OF THE
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION AND ALLOW
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION TO SPEND THE MONEY
IN THE DIESEL EMISSION
REDUCTION FUEL FUND IT GENERAL
ADMISSION TECHNOLOGIES. FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR BY BOAT. WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE JAKE DONNA YOU
REPRESENTING BALLARD POWER
SYSTEMS. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
AND TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE- PROMPT THE
JAKE DONAHUE ON THE LINE. OR IS
HE- THERE IS A THIRD OKAY
WELCOME. MISTER LANDER MEMBERS.
HEY DONNA YOU'LL BE HAVE A
SPONSOR BALLARD POWER SYSTEMS I
WILL BELIEVER THE POINT THAT
SENATOR AND- HAS EFFECTIVELY
CONVEYED IN HIS TESTIMONY BUT I
DO WANT TO ADD. THAT THESE
FUNDS WERE INTENDED TO HELP
CALIFORNIA CLEAN UP DIESEL
POLLUTION OUR COMMUNITIES AND
THE OUTDATED NATURE THE CRRENT
CODE HAS PREVENTED US FROM%
DOING THAT- THIS BILL IS A
SYMBOL COMMON SENSE WAY TO
REMEDY THAT ISSUE AND I
RESPECTFULLY I HAVE A- THANK
YOU VERY. I SEE THERE ARE NO
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE GALLERY FOR IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SO WILL GO DIRECTLY TO
CALLERS ON THE LINE IF MODERATE
THE MODERATE COULD PLEASE
PROMPT SPEAKERS. FAVOR OF THIS
OF. OF PROPOSAL THIS BILL WILL
GO TO THE SPEAKERS ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE HOW MANY
SPEAKERS DO WE HAVE ANY YET ON
THIS BILL. APART PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. YOU HAVE. NINE
FORTY TWO. FIGURING OUT YOUR
MOM ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
LIKE TO TRANSPORTATION
COALITION AND SUPPORT. WE HAVE
TO MORRELL NOW I'M IN JUST A
MOMENT. NINE FIFTY THREE. YES
GOOD MORNING- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ISRAEL POLLOCK- ON
BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO GAS AND
ELECTRIC AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS- HERE TO
REGISTER OUR SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY
TWO. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
MARGARET GLAD SHE NOTHING
HAPPENED CREWS IN SUPPORT. AND
THERE'S NO ONE OUT THANK YOU AT
THE TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL MOVE TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION AND AGAIN I DO NOT
SEE ANYONE IN THE GALLERY OR IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SO WILL GO
DIRECTLY TO THE LINE MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE IN. Q. THE-
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION. TO
LEARN. DILLON CHECK IF YOU WERE
IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE ZERO.
THERE IS NO ONE Q. NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION- WILL WILL WILL-
GIVE IT A FEW MORE SECONDS
PLEASE SPEAKERS ANYBODY. IN
OPPOSITION. NOW IS THE TIME TO
PLEASE DIAL IN. VERY WELL NO
ONE IS HERE IN- TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OR AT LEAST ON THE
LINE. VERY WELL WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR A COMMENTS
QUESTIONS FOR AND ANYTHING FROM
THE COMMITTEE. ANY ACTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE ANY OF MOTIONS ON
THE BILL MOVE THE BILL. WE HAVE
A MOTION. FROM US CENTER CHIANG
THE CORRECT OKAY VERY WELL. DID
YOU WANNA MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS CENTER ARCH LETTER-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
THREE NINETY FIVE ATTILA. TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL
BY WESSEL I. MARLA HI MORE LIKE
I. BRADFORD BY BRADFORD I. CHEN
I CHEN HI. DOLLY BY GOLLY I.
DONE I THOUGHT I. HERTZBERG BY.
HERTZBERG AYE. HILL HI HILL I.
MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE I. RUBIO HI
RUBIO I. STERN HI STERN I.
WIENER AYE WIENER I TWELVE
EIGHT DAYS. NO NOS. THE BILL IS
UP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
ARCHULETA WILL MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT BILL THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SP ELEVEN SEVENTEEN ASSIST
IN MINING IS HERE ON THIS BILL
PERTAINS TO LOOK COLOR GAS
SERVICE MASTER METER CUSTOMERS
BEFORE WE BEGIN I WANT TO
REMIND THE MEMBERS AND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC AND THE CENTER
FOR. THAT YOU CAN. PART IN THE
LATE. AN THE WOMAN TO THAT WE
HAVE HERE AND THEN SHE TO
ACCOUNT FOR EVERYONE'S HEALTH
PARTICIPATING IN THIS PROCESS
WE WILL- TRY TO EXPEDITE THE
SYRIANS MUCH AS POSSIBLE BY. I
AM FOR PERMITTING A TOTAL OF
THREE MINUTES OF ARGUMENTS ON
BOTH SIDES ALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY MUCH LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND OTHER POSITION
ON THIS MEASURE CENTER MONEY IN
WELCOME. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
GOOD MORNING NUMBERS PLUS THE
JOIN YOU IN WHEN I THINK STAFF
FOR GAP IN SUPPORT OUR- TURN
INTO FIVE APPROACH HERE DURING
COVERT NINETEEN. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO ACCEPT THE PROPOSED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS TO ADD
SAVINGS FROM THE CLIMATE CREDIT
THROUGH THE SUB METER PROCESS.
SB ELEVEN SEVENTEEN ELIMINATES
A STATUTORY CONFLICT IN
EXISTING LAW TO PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS TO RESIDENTS SUCH
AS MOBILE HOME APARTMENT
RESIDENTS BY ENSURING RATES
CHART. MR RIGHT THROUGH TO
METERS BASED ON THE LIKE
PROVIDERS ACTUAL RESIDENTS RATE.
CURRENTLY ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS AND OTHER THIRD
PARTY BILLERS ARE CHARGING SET
METER ACCOUNT SET THE ELECTRIC
CORPORATION RATE FOR
ELECTRICITY EVEN IF THE AREA IS
SERVED BY A COMMUNITY CHOI AT
THE GATE. WITH THE CURRENT RATE
THIS IS OCCURRING SPECIFICALLY
IN MOBILE HOME PARKS THIS
RESULTS IN PARK RESIDENTS BEING
DENIED SAVINGS ARE BENEFITS
FROM THE CCA ENABLES MOBILE
HOME PARK OPERATORS. GET THE
SAVINGS YOU THEY ALREADY NJOY
A DIFFERENT SHOW PROFIT OVER
AND ABOVE WHAT THEY'RE CHARGED
AT THE MASTER METER. THE SEARCH
I HAVE BEEN. WITH THE GOLDEN
STATE MANY HOME OWNERS LEAGUE
TO TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT IN
MEMBERS I WILL RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
THANK INTO WE HAVE MISTER
STANTON IN PERSON OR ON THE
LINE. YES GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
WHO SAID MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BY DAVID IS PRETTY
STATUS IT OUT THE GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR THE GOLDEN STATE
MANUFACTURED HOME OWNERS WEEK.
AT A TIME TESTIFYING THIS
MORNING IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WE WILL APPARATED A BIT FURTHER
INTO MASTER PETERED MOBILE HOME
PARK THE **** PETER GAS AND
YOUR ELECTRIC SYSTEM RUNS FROM
THE **** PETER AT THE ST. TO
EACH OF THE INDIVIDUAL METERS
LOCATED AT. ACES BUT THE PARKER
TAKES OVER OPERATION OF THE
SYSTEM FOR THE SERVING UTILITY
IT BECOMES RESPONSIBLE FOR
BUILDING AND REPAIRING AND
MAINTAINING THE SYSTEM
STRUCTURE. IN RECOGNITION OF
THE AVOIDED COST TO THE SERVING
UTILITY. USUALLY THE PARKERS
AUTHORIZED TO PURCHASE THE
ENERGY THAT DISCOUNTED
WHOLESALE RATE. AND BILL IT TO
THE RESIDENTS AT A HIGHER
RETAIL RATE WE CALL THIS THE
DIFFERENTIAL DISCOUNT. THERE'S
NO REQUIREMENT THIS BODY BE
ACCOUNTED FOR HELD A- INTEREST
BEARING ACCOUNTS. ARE GOING TO
GET THE USE THAT AS A WISHES
BUT IT CONCEPT IT'S THERE TO
PAY FOR THE OPERATION ACOSTA
SYSTEM. YES HAVE WEALTH BUT A
LANDMARK CASE IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE YOU SEE TO MAKE
SURE THAT PARK OTERS COULD NOT
CHARGE RESIDENTS. MORE THAN
THESE RATES THEY'RE ENTITLED.
TO BILL AND SEVEN THIRTY NINE
POINT FIVE THE SEPTIC DID THIS
BILL IS AT THE HEART OF THAT.
PROBLEM HERE IS THAT RECENT
YEARS WE- DO PUT OUT OUT OF
THIRD PARTY LOW DISTURBING
ENTITIES. TO PROVIDE ELECTRIC
GENERATION WITHIN THE TERRITORY
OF DISTURBING YOU KILL IT. AT
THE AGGREGATE OR ENTITIES CAN
DELIVER ENERGY AT LOWER RATES.
ARE CO OWNERS AS RESULT GET ON
REGULATED DISCOUNTS UP THE
ENERGY IF THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
ON. TO THE RESIDENTS. HI IT IN
IT. TO THE STATUTORY THAT I
JUST DESCRIBED SO THESE LOWER
ELEGY RATES ARE NOT ALWAYS USED
TO BUILD THE RESIDENT. ARE YOU.
TO PREVENT THIS ADDITIONAL FREE
BODY FOR BEING COLLECTED BY
PARK OWNERS ANALOGY TERRITORIES
THERE IS THAT CITY TO A BAND
THIS LANGUAGE TO CAPTURE IT
THIRD PARTY LA ANGIE THE
LANGUAGE. THAT THE PULL UP
SEVEN THIRTY THAT CAN BE
ACHIEVED AT THAT IS THAT
RESIDENTS WILL BE BUILT AT THE
SAME RATE APPLICABLE THAT THEY
WERE RECEIVING GAS OR
ELECTRICITY DIRECTLY FROM THE
GAS ELECTRIC CORPORATION ADDING
BEACH PARTY OUT. SHE HAD
SEVERAL THE COMMITTEE AGREE
THAT THIS. CLOSED AND WE ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTED WITH THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WOULD
LIKE TO CENTER MORE LOCK. SIR
MORE LIKE IF YOU COULD JUST
TAKE OVER ON THIS PORTION OF
TAKING TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL FOR. ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES BECAUSE- I MEASURE WE
WILL AND PLEASURE MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AT THIS
TIME WE HEARD TWO ONE WITNESS I
BELIEVE FOR THE BILL. CENTER
MIND YOU HAVE A SECOND WITNESS
CURRENTLY WITNESS CAPE CENTERS
ON. FOR NOW WILL GO TO A PUBLIC
COMMENTS DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
THE GALLERY WISHING TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THIS BILL. SEE WILL
GO TO THE A SIDE ROOM AS- IS
THERE ANYONE THAT'S WILLING OR
ABLE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL. SEEING NONE WILL
PAINS MODERATOR. WE CAN TAKE
CALLS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AT
THIS TIME. IF YOU'RE IN THE FOR
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
BUT A LIGHT FIFTY EIGHT. AFTER
ME NOT CAPTION ASSOCIATES IS
THE CORE ON BEHALF OF MC AND
CAL FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MADAME MODERATOR ANY OTHER
CALLERS WILLING TO. TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF SB ONE ONE SEVEN. NOT
A LINE FIFTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS MARK
THANKS TO MAKE ON BEHALF OF
PENINSULA CLEAN ENERGY AND
VALLEY CLEAN ENERGY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU X. SPEAKER. THERE'S
NO ONE OUT IN THE QUEUE THANK
YOU IS THERE ANYONE. AVAILABLE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL DO WE HAVE ANY KEY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANYONE
IN THE GALLERY OR IN FROM
TWENTY FORTY FOUR. SEEING AND
ARE THERE ANY CALLERS MADAME
MODERATOR ON THE LINE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION. THERE'S NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE THEN WE'LL WAIT ABOUT
TEN MINUTES FOR TO FIND SOMEONE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. KATY
I'M KIDDING MADAM MODERATOR-
THAT CLOSES THE DISCUSSION I
COLLEAGUES ANYONE WISHING TO
ASK A QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL. SENATE RUBIO NOT A
QUESTION BUT I REALLY JUST WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD IT IS IN
MY OPINION. THAT MOBILE HOMES
USUALLY HOUSE THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES-
I HAVE MANY IN MY DISTRICT
USUALLY SENIORS AND DISABLED
AND SO SOMETIMES WE TEND TO
FILL- NOT. YOU KNOW BY CHOICE
ARE PURPOSELY SORT OF NEGLECT
THIS POOL OF INDIVIDUALS AND
THEY SEEM TO HAVE. WAY MORE
CHALLENGES THAT HOMEOWNERS TO
AND AGAIN IN MY DISTRICT I'VE
DEALT WITH MANY ISSUES WHERE
OTHER TREATED DIFFERENTLY FOR
ONE REASON OR THE OTHER AND I
THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT.
BILL TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
TAKING CARE OF AND I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK THE OPTED TO ADD ME WHEN
EVER APPROPRIATE TO THIS BILL
IS CLOUT THIRTEEN KIA. YOU IN.
SPEAKER THIS BILL. SEEING NONE
SO. MONNING WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MAKE A CLOSING STATEMENT YEAH
JUST VERY BRIEFLY ON A THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY AND
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND HIS
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK WITH THIS
ON THIS BILL WHEN I THINK
SENATOR RUBIO FOR HER COMMENTS.
IN SUPPORT. IN THE FINAL CLOSE.
THIS IS A MATTER OF BASIC
EQUITY. IN NORMAL TIMES. DURING
THIS CRISIS OF COVERT NINETEEN.
EVERY DOLLAR SAVED CAN BE A
DOCTOR THE GOES TO GROCERIES-
AND NOT INTO AN OVER PURGED
ENERGY BILL SO. AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLYASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER MIGHT ENJOY A MOTIONS
DODD. THE BILL. ITEM IN A. MATT
SECRETARY WOULD YOU BE TAKE
ROLE AND THIS IS A MOTION AS
AMENDED YES. SB ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN MONEY S. AS AMENDED
TO THE FLOOR. WHAT'S SO. WITH
SO I. MORE LIKE FIVE MORE LIKE
A FIVE. BRADFORD HI BRADFORD I.
CHIANG BY CHIANG I. DOLLY HI
DOLLY I. DODD HI DODD I.
HERTZBERG BY THE I. HERTZBERG
I'D- HILL. HI HILL I. MCGUIRE
HI MCGUIRE I. RUBIO FIVE RUBIO
I. STERN HI STERN I. WIENER HI
WIENER I. TWELVE DAYS NO NOS.
THANK YOU THAT BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU SENATOR MINING. THAT
BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN ZERO THREE
PRESENTED BY THE WORLD FAMOUS
SENATOR HUESO. FAMOUS KERRY
MUCH THEY'RE MORE LIKE MEMBERS
THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO PRESENT
AS BE FORTINO THREE A BILL O
EXPAND THE INCOME ELIGIBILITY
FOR LOW INCOME ENERGY SAVINGS
ASSISTANCE. PROGRAMS THE
ELECTRICITY A SAVINGS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IS ONE OF
THE STATE'S LONGEST AND IN
ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS THE
ESA PROVIDES NO COST HOME
WEATHERIZATION SERVICES ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MEASURES AND MINOR
HOME FIRST TO LOW INCOME
FAMILIES SERVE BY OUR STATES
FOR LARGEST ENERGY ENERGY
UTILITIES. THE PROGRAM HELPS TO
CONSERVE ENERGY REDUCE ENERGY
ALSO IMPROVE HEALTH. AND SAFETY
IT SUPPORTS JOBS AND
DISADVANTAGED LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ALL THE WHILE
HELPING TO ADVANCE THIS IS.
WHAT GOALS. THAT ELIGIBLE
ELIGIBLE LIMóN HAS NOT BEEN A
JUST IN FIFTY. YEARS THIS BILL
WOULD APPLY THE LOW INCOME
DEFINITION USED IN THE ANNUAL
LIMITS PUBLISHED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING. AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT THAT WOULD BE BASED
ON THE U. S. HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT GUIDELINES. I
UTILIZING THE H. E. D. INCOME
LIMITS THE COST OF LIVING AND
REGIONAL ECONOMIC CONDITIONS
WILL BE BETTER REFLECTED I ALSO
WANT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT IN NO
WAY. IS THIS BILL INCREASING
THE CURRENT BUDGETS FOR THE
ESTá PROGRAM WHEN I TOOK IT ON
I TOOK OFF THIS BILL WITH
WITHOUT AN INTEREST TO
INCREASED- THE- THE CHARGES. A
REPAIRS. THE END OF. BUT TO.
MATTER IN THIS BILL OR IN THE
IN THE CURRENT LAW THAT HAS
CREATED- BUDGET SURPLUSES IN
THIS PROGRAM WHEN WE MOST NEED
TO CREATE. ENERGY EFFICIENCY IN
THE STATE. THE CONDITIONS OF
THE CONDITIONS CAUSED BY THIS
COVERT PANDEMIC- THIS BILL WILL
HELP PUT PEOPLE BACK TO WORK IN
OUR COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY IN
COMMUNITIES LIKE THE ONES THAT
I REPRESENT THAT HAVE BEEN VERY
THAT BEEN HIT HARD. BY THIS
PANDEMIC I HAVE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATES IN
THE STATE CURRENTLY IN MY
DISTRICT SO THIS BILL WOULD OF
THE- HELPFUL PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK. AND ALLOW REPAIRS TO SAVE
ON ENERGY BILLS- THIS BILL BY
EXPANDING THE DEFINITION OF LOW
INCOME ELIGIBILITY WOULD HELP
TO ENSURE. MORE OF CALIFORNIANS
FINANCIALLY STRUGGLING WITH
FAMILIES FAMILIES FINANCIALLY
STRUGGLING FAMILIES WILL BE
SERVED. SO I HAVE A WITNESS ON
THE LINE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OR POTENTIAL LUPUS IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR EL
CONCILIO OF SAN MATEO COUNTY
MISTER CHAIR IF FOR ORDERED
OFFICE WOULD BE ALLOWED TO
TOUCH. TODAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. SENATE HUESO AGAIN JUST A
REMINDER THAT LEAD WITNESSES
GET THREE MINUTES TO SPEAK AND
THEN THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY
ON BEHALF OR IN OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL. WILL BE LIMITED TO
GIVING THEIR NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION SO AT THIS TIME WE
WELCOME MISS LOPEZ. SHE YES
GOOD MORNING. YES GOOD MORNING-
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELL LET THANK
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ARE CAN TELL OKAY I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A
CONTINUOUS ON THE TAIL COUNTY
THEY CRIED THE ONE TWO THREE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION.
COMMITTED TO INCREASE EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS AND ACCESS TO
QUALITY OF LIFE SERVICES
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES ON THE
TELEPHONE. I HAD THE OF
ADDRESSING YOU TODAY THE COURT
OF SENATE BILL FOURTEEN. THE
HOME WEATHERIZATION LOW INCOME
CUSTOMER. BILL BEING. BY
CANNELLA. THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE MUCH TO CALL BY INCOME
AND THIS IS FAN BY TAKING IT
TOOK THE HIGH COST OF. A
SPECIAL WORKING CREATED TO CALL
COULD THE MID OF THE OF
CALIFORNIA SILICON FAMILY THE
DIFFERENT IF I STAY. WITHOUT
ANY TO BUT- FOR YOUR IS GOING
TO THAT'S WHY TO IT SHOULD BE
PROVIDER DELIVERING. LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM KNOWN AS
THE PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM WHICH
WIDE IT IS NOT BY STATUTE TO
PROVIDE LOCAL SO MUCH SERVICE
AND ENERGY FUNCTION LOW INCOME
IN A TO BAN COMMUNITY. THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. INCOME ELIGIBILITY
GREAT THAT HAD NOT BEEN EJECTED
IN ALMOST FIFTEEN YEARS. 102%
OF THE LOW FEDERAL POVERTY
GUIDELINES REGARDING THE
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION. THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL STANDARD
MAKE SURE NATIONAL DIVIDE THE
COULD NOT BE FLAT CALIFORNIA
CONDITION NO I TO BANDS.
OUTDATED GUIDELINE YOU HAVE
EXCLUDE HELP MISTER AND THE
FAMILIES LIVING OUT OF SMALL
EXPENSIVE AND. KATIE IN LOW
WITH A SHE PROGRAM MEANT TO
HELP SUCH MA'AM. SOME OF YOUR
VALUABLE TO THE MOST PLACES IN
THE UNITED STATES LARGELY DUE
TO A HOUSING. AS OF THE CURRENT
INCOME CRITERIA BECAUSE WHO
LOOK AND THEY LIFE NO ONE
DISADVANTAGED BECAUSE CAN
QUALIFY. THESE ARE PLEASE THE
BECAUSE. GOING YOU SIR YEAH
THEY ARE EXCLUDED FROM PARTY.
FOR EXAMPLE A SINGLE MOTHER
WITH ONE CHILD THIRTY SIXTEEN
DOLLARS AND TWENTY SEVEN HOW
WHEN I QUALIFY BECAUSE YOU GOT.
TO THE SENATE SEAL CONNIE WAIT
OF APPROX THIRTY COULD EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLAR YOU. CHECK PAY
TAXES WENT QUICKLY AND ONE THAT
UP WITH AVERAGES WELL THE
THOUSAND IN MY- FOR UTILITIES
BIKE AND PUT ON THE TO. I BET
THE PENSIONS OUR RECORDS WANT
THAT FAR. NO REASON QUESTION
WHAT COULD THAT THE MOTHER'S.
LOW INCOME. YET SHE WILL NOT. A
SERVICE THAT WILL HELP QUICKLY
HER CALL. THANK YOU TO THE TO
HELP SAFETY AND WELFARE. CHECK.
WE ARE GRATEFUL BUT THEN ON THE
WAY OF THAT NOW MINT THAT NO
ONE FROM CUSTOMER HE HE SAID HE
CRIED. BUT THE REALITY
TELEVISION AT EIGHTY GOT. IF
PASSED. SENATE BILL COURT YOU
DON'T. WILL ALLOW CUSTOM IN AN
ALARM THAT. THE OLD HAVE A HIGH
COST OF LIVING OUR STATE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM.
SENATE BILL POINT YOU KNOW.
THANK YOU VERY OKAY ON YOU
SUPPOSED. AT THE VATICAN. BUT
OF THE SCHOOL DAM NORTH ANY
OTHER LOW INCOME. THAT WILL
ALLOW ONE. VOICE UNDER THE PUT.
NO I DID THE. MY POINT
REPUBLICAN GUBERNATORIAL
ADMINISTRATION. FORMER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. OUT OF DEMONSTRATE A
LOAN COULD JUSTICE IS GOING TO
AND A SMALL BIT BALL MORE AS
WELL AS ALLEN WAIT THOUGH IS
THE CHAIR OF THE ENERGY COUNTS
SO AND THE CONTRACT. BOB YEAH
BOB THANK YOU ARE CAN'T YEAH
AND AFTER AS A SINCERE AND
DEPOT. LOW INCOME OVERSIGHT
BOARD ESTABLISHED BY THIS VERY
BODY- IN SACRAMENTO EIGHT
CONNECTION WITH ADVISING THE
COMMISSION ON LOW INCOME ENERGY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS I
PERSONALLY RISING SUPPORT- SB
FORTINO THREE AND THE WHOLE-
THAT YOU- POLICY TOWARDS
PASSAGE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ROBERT- DID YOU MENTION THERE'S
ALSO AN ELEMENT RATE GO WHO IS
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN ZERO THREE. IF WE
COULD JUST MEDICAL TO THE OF.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT GREAT
HAVING HEARD THE KEY WITNESSES
ARE THERE ANY. INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
SP FOUR KING OF THREE IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NINE ROOM THREE
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NONE PAT A
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
INDIVIDUALS ON THE LINE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FORTINO THREE. FINALLY HAVE
LINE SIXTY PLEASE I HAD. THE
SAID HE MINOR ON BEHALF DURING
CLEAN ENERGY SUPPORT IN THE
CLINICAL FOR. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE LINE THE ONE. HI MY NAME.
THE CALIFORNIA EACH STATION SEE
AND FRIEND MANAGEMENT COUNSEL
AND THE COURT. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE JUST A FEW MORE MY MOMMY.
MINE TWELVE. HI THIS IS ALAN
RAY GO NOT PRESIDENT ENERGY
FISHY COUNCIL AND WE DO SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ONE ONE MOMENT. ANYONE ELSE OUT
OF THE LINE FIFTY NINE. CAR
QUICK THE AB. REPORTER MATTER
YEAH. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
BUT A LINE. SEVENTEEN MITCHELL
OREO FROM THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
COUNSEL OF RECORD. THANK YOU.
BOTTOM LINE FIFTY FOUR. FIND
FIFTY FOUR DO YOU HAVE A
COMMUNITY.
NINE FIFTY FOUR.
THERE IS NO ONE OUT THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR NOW DO WE HAVE ANY%
KEY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TO
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN ZERO THREE.
GOOD MORNING MR VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY AT THE
REQUIREMENT THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. AS THE
PERSON EITHER UP IN A FAMILY
STRUGGLING TO PAY FOR ME THESE
IN A LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS I
TRULY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
ACCORDING CALL INSURING THAT
LOW INCOME. OLD MANAGE. THEY
ALMOST FINDS IN THE HOME RUN OR
THE AND. HOWEVER WE ARE
UNFORTUNATE IN A TO MY AMENDED
PETITION THE CURRENT OF THE
BILL. BECAUSE PROGRAM IS FUNDED
BY ALL RATEPAYERS AND BECAUSE
OF THE TECHNIQUE MATTER IN
WHICH PROGRAMMING. TO BE A MAN
IN THE OFFICE HI RED. IN
ADDITION CALIFORNIA. GREAT WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMISSION OF
THE ALL AND MONSTER'S OF THE
BILL FORTY A MANNER THAT WE THE
THREAT OF RATE INCREASE. TO
REVIEWING AND THEN. THANK THANK
YOU MS SILVER THROUGH ARE THERE
ANY. WE HAVE ANOTHER OPPOSITION
WITNESS HEARING NONE WE WILL
NOW GO TO THE GALLERY SEE A
THREE INDIVIDUALS TO. TESTIFIED
OPPOSITION SAYING NINE WILL GO.
ROOM TWENTY. SEEING NONE MADAME
MODERATOR OVER BACK TO YOU. IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. AND THERE IS
NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THAT BRINGS THE BILL BACK
TO THE- COMMITTEE CALL. AS
ANYONE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR. MISTER
CHAIR IF I COULD PLEASE SENATOR
HILL THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I JUST IT WAS SO NICE TO
HEAR A MY GOOD FRIEND ATTENTION
LOPEZ AND AB SIGNON CEMETERY
COUNTY WHO. HAS BEEN THERE AND
WORKED SO HARD FOR SO MANY
YEARS FOR THE PEOPLE OF THE
COUNTY AND THOSE WHO ARE
DISADVANTAGED IN NEED. AS MUCH
HELP AS THEY CAN ESPECIALLY
WITH HER HOUSING AND- WITH
EVERY EVERY NEEDED SAY- THEY
POSSESSED SO THANK YOU
ATTENTION FOR BEING PART OF
THIS CONVERSATION AND I IS A
WONDER WILL AND I'M HAPPY MOVE.
TODAY THANK YOU HERE SENATE
BILL IN THE BILL DO YOU HAVE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION. JUST
CURIOUS MISTER CHAIR BY COULD
ASK. ONE QUESTION IN LIGHT OF
EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENING
AROUND THIS- IT ALMOST SEEMS
AS- ALMOST A GOOD PERCENTAGE OF
OUR STATE ONE OUT OF FIVE WILL
BE LOW. INCOME OR NO INCOME.
HOW WILL THAT IMPACT. RATES ON
THE REST OF. THE BILL IS
WRITTEN RATE NEUTRAL IT HAS NO
LANGUAGE- GIVEN ANY AUTHORITY
TO THE PC TO INCREASE RATES TO.
BROADEN THE PROGRAM WE ARE
SIMPLY. AND IN ELIGIBILITY TO
MAKE EXISTING FUNDS ELIGIBLE
FOR- THESE PROGRAMS SO THERE
THERE HAS BEEN- A SURPLUS OF
FUNDS IN THIS PROGRAM FOR MANY
YEARS AND- BECAUSE OF. THE
INCOME- ADJUSTMENT HASN'T BEEN
MADE IN FIFTEEN YEARS THERE'S
LESS STRONG ON THESE FUNDS WHEN
WE REALLY NEED THESE FUNDS TO
IMPROVE ENERGY EFFICIENCY SO
WHEN THEY SPEAK OF THIS BILL
CAUSING PRESSURE. I DON'T KNOW
THAT- IT'S ANY MORE PRESSURE
THAN ALREADY EXISTS ON THE PC
TO DO ANYTHING IN THIS WRITTEN
IN THIS. HI A UNIVERSE FROM
THIS AREA- I DON'T KNOW HOW
THIS BILL INCREASES PRESSURE IT
IT'S SIMPLY ALLOWS MORE PEOPLE
TO QUALIFY- BUT THERE IS NO
PROVISION IN THE BILL THAT
ALLOWS FOR RATES INCREASE I
TOOK THIS ON- THE THIS BILL ON
WHAT THE- THE SOLE CONDITION
THAT IT WOULD NOT RESULT. IN A
RATE INCREASE BUT I DO SEE THE
NEED TO GET THIS MONEY INTO OUR
COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY NOW. WHEN
WE HAVE A ECONOMIC CRISIS
SITUATION OUR STATE AND SOME OF
THE HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT LEVELS
NOW- FACING OUR STATE AND ITS
HISTORY- GETTING PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT BUT ALSO TRANSFERRING
THAT WORK IN A SAVINGS REPAIRS
IS GOING TO BE. SO IN THIS
PROCESS. I WOULD TO TELL THE
OPPOSITE JIM THIS BILL IS NOT
INTENDED TO INCREASE RATES
THERE'S NO PROVISION IN IT THAT
WOULD INCREASE RATES. IF YOU
LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE THAT
DOESN'T EVEN. PROVIDE DIRECTION
TO INCREASE RATES SHOULD THE
VINCENT SHOULD THE FUNDS- GO
DOWN- SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE
TO DO THE IT'S NOT WRITTEN IN
THE BILL SO- I DON'T THINK AND
I HOPE THAT IT DOESN'T RESULT.
IN AN INCREASE RATES EVEN IF
THE- OF THE PC THREATS PLENARY.
PLANNER THIRTY DECIDE TO DO
THEIR ON THEIR OWN REGARD I
DON'T. NECESSARILY THINK THEY
WOULD BUT- IF THEY DO IT
WOULDN'T BE A RESULT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU CENTER HUESO
WOULD THAT BE YOUR CLOSING
STATEMENT. SURE HANK YOU VERY
MUCH MY CLOSING STATEMENT WOULD
BE SIMPLY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GREAT THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
IF YOU COULD PLEASE CALL. THE
ROLE SB FORTINO THREE WESSEL
DID PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WESSEL FIVE WESSEL I. MORE LIKE.
BRADFORD HI BRADFORD I. CAN.
DOLLY. DOT HI DODD I. HERTZBERG
BY HERTZBERG GUY. HILL HI HILL
I. MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE I. RUBIO
HI RUBIO AYE. STERN HI STERN I.
WIENER HI WIENER I. NINE EIGHT
ZERO ON THOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY AGAIN THE BILL
PASSES. TURN THE- CERTAINLY
BACK OVER TO YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU CENTER MORE LOCK AND
THANK YOU TO ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND ALSO TO
EVERYONE IN THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROCESS. I
ALSO WANT TO ENCOURAGE THOSE
THAT WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFIED
TODAY OR FOR SOME REASON
COULDN'T GET THEIR COMMENTS
INTO TODAY FOR WHATEVER REASONS
BECAUSE THE RESULT OF A
TECHNOLOGY GLITCH OR A TIME
ISSUE OR ANY OTHER. MATT REASON
WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE THOSE TO
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SET ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE OR
PLEASE VISIT OUR RIGHT WEBSITE
WHERE YOU CAN ALSO PROVIDE
COMMENTS THROUGH THAT FORUM
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO US.
AND WE WANT INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN PART OF CHAU
RECORDS THESE LAWS ARE FOR THE
PUBLIC THEY AFFECT YOU THE MOST
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE. THAT
YOU COMMENT ON MATTERS THAT
AFFECT YOUR LIVES THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE
THROUGH AND COOPERATION THROUGH
THIS EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TIME
AND I KNOW MANY PEOPLE ARE ARE
SUFFERING OUT THERE AND
STRUGGLING. WITH THE CONDITIONS
IMPOSED BY THE PANDEMIC WE HAVE
NOW CONCLUDED OUR AGENDA THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY TO
LEASING COMMUNICATIONS. IS NOW
ADJOURNED EVERYONE HAVE A
WONDERFUL DAY.